Ben was in a league of his own he was a  couple time Hodge Trophy winner which is  essentially the Heisman of wrestling  um and but Ben and I traveled Ben was  yeah Ben Ben was Ben is one of the best  NCAA college wrestlers of all time when  he came out how many game how many fight  win streak did he have I don't remember  what the number one he did well he  didn't lose until he didn't lose until  he came into the UFC Masala was his  first loss and he was like 21-0 that was  the one when Mazda knocked him out in  three seconds  that's three my bad brother seconds over  here  uh you know but so Ben was in a league  of his own and those two guys wouldn't  exactly give you much confidence because  I always lost to them and they also had  the big brother they had the big brother  did you ever need him did you ever beat  him I took Tyron down one time I took  Ben down one time I think maybe in a you  know five years of